marie noëlle de l'année bonjour bonjour
bonjour la martinique alors vous êtes
candidate de la france insoumise sur la
première circonscription celle du centre
qu'est ce qui a motivé votre candidature
pourquoi vous présentez alors je me
présente je me suis engagée déjà auprès
des insoumis parce qu'à la lecture du
programme la venue en commun j'ai
découvert un programme
construit
cohérent et réfléchie réfléchi où
l'humain est mis au coeur
des réflexions et des décisions prises
ça m'a redonné espoir ça m'a réconforté
et parce que ça exprime complètement ce
que je veux laisser à mes enfants à ma
circonscription et à la martinique
si facile pour une femme aujourd'hui de
s'engager il n'y a que 17 femmes
candidates
sur les 57 candidats tôt dit cette femme
si facile aujourd'hui pour une femme de
s'engager
mais en fait on s'engage en fonction de
ses convictions moi je suis là
aujourd'hui parce que mes convictions
m'ont porté là c'était pas quelque chose
que j'avais prévu
c'était pas dont ça faisait pas partie
de mes rêves tout simplement mais je
suis là parce que j'ai commencé à lutter
contre la réforme des retraites la crise
qu vide est arrivé j'étais en plein
dedans et les lois liberticides le pass
and i ter l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants tous ces injustices m'ont
porté devant vous aujourd'hui en fait
donc est-ce que c'est facile c'est pas
facile mais je supporte et par mes
pauvres fiction et j'y vais et je ferai
avec je verrais bien alors qu'elles sont
sur la circonscription sur la martinique
en général quels sont les trois projets
que vous pouvez présenter sur lesquels
les trois projets qui sont importants
pour vous
auf les trois projets importants pour la
martinique vous toute façon
les commence à baisser
je suppose qu'il ya aussi la santé via
suppose qu'il ya la vie chère toute
façon les martiniquais connaissent le
programme de l'avenir en commun ils ont
voté aux élections présidentielles à
53,23 pourra plus de 53% prose programme
et ils ont choisi comme étant ceux qui
leur convenait le mieux c'est vrai qu'il
ya quand même des mesures que je vais
porter comme la défense de l'hôpital
public et la prise en charge des soins
des patients des patients je vais
travailler avec
les parlementaires pour abroger la loi
la loi du 5 août
2021 sur l'obligation vaccinale
d'aidé soignant le pass and it et en le
pass vaccinale et de façon à réintégrer
les soignants suspendu et les ramener
vers véreux à l'hôpital auprès de leurs
patients parce que ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est que l'offre de soins
diminue de manière
catastrophique et il ya des pertes de
chance donc il faut absolument il est
important que les soignants retourne à
l'hôpital qu'on puisse prendre en charge
chaque martiniquais que chaque
martiniquais puisse avoir un diagnostic
posé en temps et en heure et que la
prison choix enfants soient
soit
équivalente par rapport à l'hexagone ce
dossier qui vous tient à coeur parce que
vous êtes vous-même infirmières oui je
suis moins donc vous êtes vous avez les
mains dans le cambouis un peu dire ah
oui et puis depuis deux ans on se bat
avec les patients se bat avec
pour la prise en charge des patientes
qui est complètement dégradée en fait
parce que déjà les hôpitaux sont donc
des mauvais dans un mauvais état donc il
faudrait reconstruire les hôpitaux de
proximité des quais trinité lamentin et
pour donner l'accès aux soins à tous et
dans le programme de l'avenir en commun
il est question du 100% sécurité sociale
pour tous les soins prescrits donc
vraiment au niveau de la santé il faut
vraiment investir dans l'hôpital tant au
niveau des moyens humains tant au niveau
de des moyens des équipements pour
redonner la possibilité à chaque
martiniquais de se soigner correctement
et éliminer la perte de chance alors
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire ça si la
dernière question le aux électeurs pour
les convaincre de voter pour vous ali
alors pour je vais leur dire qu aux
atouts les laventinois les trinitéens
les franciscains les gros mornais les
aubertin je leur dis qu
au premier tour des élections ils ont
voté ils ont voté jean luc mélenchon
nous étions 70 nous étions dix sept
mille bord dont nous étions dix sept
mille à voter pour le programme de
l'avenir en commun donc je les invite à
recommencer à recommencer le 11 et le 12
juin en votant marie noëlle de l'année
pour qu'on puisse
avoir une majorité pour que les insoumis
puisse avoir une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et contrer la politique
désastreuse des manuels macron
merci madame marie noëlle de l'année
[Musique]